اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
تعلن عن هويه منفذ عمليه معبر الاوجه
الحدودي مع مصر والذي قتل ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين وتقول انه الجندي المصري محمد
صلاح وعمره 22 عاما وكان يسكن في القاهره
وتعلن تسليم جثمانه الى مصر بينما لم تعلن
اي جهه رسميه مصريه حتى الان عن هويه
المنفذ
مؤسس مجموعه ايفاجنير يقول ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعادت مناطق في شمالي
المدينه وكيف تقول انها دمرت دبابات للواء
الثالث الروسي خلال تقدمها في محور باخوت
وحاكم دونيتس كالموالي لروسيا يصف الوضع
على خط التماس قرب ضخمه بالصعب للغايه بعد
اعلاني واشنطن ان سفينه صينيه قامت
بمناوره غير امنه بالقرب من مدمره امريكيه
في مضيق تايوان بجين تتهم واشنطن باثاره
المشاكل وتقول ان الاجراءات التي يتخذها
الجيش ضروريه للتعامل مع الاستفزازات
ووزير الدفاع الامريكي ينفت اتهام الصين
لبلاده بالسعي لتاسيس حلف على غرار النيتو
في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ اعلى وقع
دعوه لخفض التصعيد والتهدئه مبعوثان
اوروبي وامريكي يصلني الى بريشتينا بعد
زياره لبحث الازمه في كوسوفو بينما تجمع
محتجون صرب امام بلديه شمل كوسوفو اليوم
الحادي عشر مطالبين بسحب القوات الخاصه
لشرطه كوسوفو من المكان وعدم دخول رؤساء
البلديات المنتخبين الى مقر عمله
[موسيقى]
الى اللقاء